oh what a bachelor night guys i'm lauren
zima and the bachelor was only one hour
long this week but it still gave us
plenty to discuss first we finally saw
nick vile and ex andy Dorfman's big
conversation and they buried the hatchet
do you look back and you're like damn I
shouldn't have said why would you make
love with me if you weren't happening
I've I didn't take till now to probably
be like and find out the best move for
that I've always been sorry then Nick
sent home this season
sexy standout Corrine yes right before
fantasy suites but our girl Corrine
cemented herself as far more than a sex
symbol with this unforgettably epic limo
speech exit
I'm going to be me and whatever happens
happens
but I will never kiss up to a man ever
again in my life I want to go to sleep
you go Corrine elympios last Nick headed
to Finland for his final three women
this is the most northern place I've
ever been
but would things go south or would
fantasy suites heat up the finish cold
yes lots of puns to be had here and
maybe lots of you know what now we
didn't see all of fantasy suites but we
did get this bombshell from Raven I've
only been with one person my last
boyfriend my ex I was intimate with I
never made me orgasm was not expecting
that Wow
what did you guys think of ravens big
confession I have to say I admired her
it's a tough topic and she talked about
it let me know over on Twitter
you